واضيف
للشيخ فور
ابراميه هي مساله خاصه بالشعب الايراني ما
قمنا به نحن وضمان تسليط الضوء على شجاعه
المراه الايرانيه ومساعدتها على التعبير
عن التغيير الذي ترغب في التعبير عنه في
ايران ولكن في الختام هذه تظاهرات تقودها
المراه الايرانيه والشعب الايراني ونحن
متضامن معهما واذكر بان هذه الحمله هي
حمله الشعب الايراني تبعت من خلالها رساله
الى النظام الايراني ومن حق هذه الحمله
التعبير عن رغباتها لحكمتها التي بدورها
عليها الاصغاء لشعبها سانتقل الى موضوع
الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا قبل ايام سقطت
صواريخ على الاراضي البولنديه هل كانت هذه
صواريخ روسيه استهدفت بولندا وهي دوله عضو
في نيته
الجيش مازلنا ننتظر التفاصيل النهائيه
للتحقيقات في مساله الصواريخ التي سقطت في
بولندا ما نعرفه هو ان الصواريخ ومنظومات
الدفاع ضد الصواريخ هي استجابه مباشره
لهجمات روسيا ضد اوكرانيا واستهداف روسيا
للبنى التحتيه في اعماق اوكرانيا وكل ما
يجري الان وكل الصواريخ التي تعبر في سماء
اوروبا هي نتيجه الاعتداء روسي على جارتها
سنستمر بدعم اوكرانيا بينما هي تدافع عن
نفسها ضد العدوان عليها وسنستمر بدفع
روسيا الى الانسحاب من اوكرانيا كما سنلط
الضوء على الافراد والشركات التي تزود
روسيا بالاسلحه في شكل غير قانوني ومن ابي
ذلك من خلال فرض العقوبات على الافراد
والشركات الايرانيه التي زودت روسيا
بالمسيرات الهجوميه والتي استخدمتها روسيا
بدورها لمهاجمه المدنيين في اوكرانيا